yeah like one one thing i've always
wondered is pretty much how you
how you like blew up onto the scene
because i think like you blew up
immediately
um in terms of like sound in terms of
being a composer which is like i i find
it's really rare but i think a big part
of that was just that opening scene in
made in abyss
where it was just like the instrumental
with like the vocals as well and it was
just no dialogue it was just like a
montage just using using this opening
track and it just like immediately it
not only did it sell you on the show but
it just like put your work onto the map
like how did that come about was that
planned or was that just like a happy
coincidence um i was like totally lucky
and i'm glad i was um like almost
because i i had a different track i had
a much more subtle track in mind for
that right um
uh called um swings and roundabouts that
was like kind of my original idea for
that thing so it was supposed to be like
oh let's do these nice kind of really
cool textures and stuff as that's the
light kind of come on coming over but
then the sound director um and the
director decided differently to kind of
because they you don't write these
unless it's a movie or it's a specific
scene that's been requested to be
written synchronized to picture yeah all
the music is written what's called free
right then then it's synced later
oh yeah so that that wasn't meant to be
synced absolutely originally the like my
like vision of it was to be different
but um uh the director and the um the
director and the sound director
obviously had a pretty deep discussion
they decided to
to put that song there and even better
they've decided to put it there with
minimal dialogue and sound effects which
yeah ridiculously like lucky yeah and so
just to you know i guess just to like
how did how to even explain this
to see that happen and to be so happily
wrong
right like what my vision was yeah yeah
everything else to say oh man thank god
people are smarter than me but um like
because that song the song was written
just as sort of an uh kind of almost
just like another like trying to make
another palette for the soundtrack
when you start it you're just kind of
going through like point after point
after point so okay well let's just try
and write a piece of music based off
this manga panel yeah write a piece of
music based off this description or this
idea you know obviously you're like
reading through the content stuff
so i was thinking like oh yeah they must
what do they give you i'm like oh yeah
you can just go to the manga most of the
time right yeah
yeah mango or in target you got manga as
far as right yeah yeah that it's really
it really is helpful i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah super helpful and so
just
when when when you're able to like kind
of look at what is but essentially you
can just see the entire story kind of
pan out obviously you're given like
anime specific materials as well which
is super helpful
but um yeah
when you're just trying to find
something that actually kind of
hopefully
like
what's the best word respects the
content as well yeah yeah yeah
um you know you you're kind of creating
you're you're adding an audio element
that was not there before yeah as the
manga might be there before so there
might be reference that you know people
might be able to reference the anime to
the manga yeah okay well this is similar
this is different something like that
right music ever existed so yeah
um it's both freeing and also kind of
terrifying to yeah you know potentially
yeah that's the thing because like when
i saw that scene i was like this is so
perfect for this opening scene it must
have been like specifically made for
this one scene right
it was made around it was made around
like scenes like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah i would almost describe it more as
like it was almost an impression of the
show itself yeah did you did you feel
like because that was your first was
that your first anime work no sir it was
uh that's what jesus map that was my
third
yeah
okay oh wow all right wow okay so no the
first one was it's always the same
company kinema citrus but uh right did
uh something called nine
oh yeah oh yeah yeah okay
so uh nine is well actually it was a
video game and it's actually a video
game i did with uimatsu like way back
when so he oh
a couple years later when i started
doing anime for this company called
kenneman citrus they said we're actually
doing an anime of nor 9 as well right
and so that i i did so you were like the
natural picture yeah maybe that was it
yeah maybe maybe that was it because i
mean i guess i guess you know it makes
sense to get the guy who did the game
yeah yeah yeah yeah so
yeah yeah i didn't think about it
is that not obvious
that's what your head now in my [ __ ]
30s just [ __ ] sipping sparkling water
no i don't know what happened to the
liquids like that wasn't like a
five-head observation
absorber
i was also doing something called under
the dog which was a a
kickstarter oh
it kickstart over here and that was that
came first and so yeah i didn't know
like how everything kind of progressed
but um i was on that for the trailer
music and then they asked if i wanted to
do the actual soundtrack yeah that was
so cool because that was like that was
the first one that was i was like oh wow
i had no idea i was like well happy
about that yeah yeah i've been like you
know just [ __ ]
feel like a better word fantasizing
about [ __ ] trying to do anime yeah
yeah yeah yeah lucky enough to do games
for a couple of years yeah yeah oh my
god
so happy about that yeah i was in
college and just finished college in in
london so i was living here at the time
i had no idea what was going to happen
boom like
like no you're an anime yeah yeah yeah
yeah you were composing for games while
in college yeah so when i did um i was
doing undergrad that's when i started
doing my stuff and then that developed
with other games both uh japanese and so
you were busy
yeah yeah i think i don't know how i did
it because i i mean again maybe maybe
we'll get to the bottom of this while
talking to you yeah you obviously got
tracked i'll make another five-head
observation
like just like like like therapy times
three
therapists times three it's like oh my
god everything makes sense it's all
connected man it's all connected
yeah so i was working throughout college
as well um and yeah just
i
it just happened i mean i was just
working names work work work work work
and just you know i i
don't do anything while at college yeah
oh okay i thought about saying anything
like in general i was like don't go down
okay so like now what i want to know
actually is like how you and god got to
know each other because like i kind of i
kind of met you guys through that right
like i made you through gone and whatnot
um so like it's like
where was the connection there
that's a pretty simple connection i hope
you remember
like a pre-story okay so connects to
that right um so i think i might have
like strongly mentioned this to sydney
or something potentially but i haven't i
don't think i've mentioned it to any of
you at least i don't remember mentioning
it um so i actually like when i was like
going through like college and stuff i
like totally felt out of anime right
right right not watching it like i
remember when i was watching all the
ghibli stuff and whatnot and some shows
like some really important shows for me
like kind of just to get into
anime kind of fandom to begin with when
i was like 14 or so then okay well out
of it kind of went totally on the ground
for a long time
and then what brought me back was doing
maiden abyss
uh because uh i was like you know it's
like one of those shows where like
creatively was the first time i felt
like oh i'm actually doing music that
really feels like me sort of thing yeah
yeah
i feel like i'm bringing like a lot of
the sort of more experimental stuff that
i learned in um primary school in
undergrad yeah yeah yeah and then like
masters in london and then that and that
was sort of like honed like film music
craft right right what was your degree
in sorry uh i did a bachelor of
composition of music technology at west
australian academy of performing arts
and then i did a masters of music for
screen composition screen wow at the
royal college of music in london
[Laughter]
oh yeah i
i mean it really kind of like honed the
craft that's one of them's like yeah
yeah
and uh just like learned how to like
produce music full film yeah yeah but uh
what whopper like focused a lot more on
experimental music or new music
a lot of arts art music
when you said waffle i thought you were
talking about
burgers
i was on a beach just eating a bunch of
whoppers experiments with music
sounds pretty accurate
um
ah like it just kind of all came
together for this like yeah this project
right yeah yeah i mean god bless
citrus man they just gave me so much so
much freedom
just kind of actually just kind of try
some things that yeah i didn't know i
could do it and i felt really good
actually just kind of going through that
process of yeah well i can i can oh i
remember like that violin technique i've
never like tried before and right
like oh i can try and like record in
this giant space in vienna that like
yeah can try and mimic like the the size
of the abyss sort of thing yeah yeah
yeah those are the techniques that like
were just introduced to me either
through undergrad or postgrad right it
was just really
nice yeah yeah
yeah yeah um what was the question
how are you in garment oh yeah
sorry there is a point to all this yeah
okay so on the back of those feel goods
you know doing events yeah um i was
curious okay how is the show doing yeah
right and i would type in in you know
the you google yourself no no i googled
this
okay is it you know how is it you know
yeah i think and all these youtuber guys
were worth trying to talk about i'm like
oh okay they're talking about it they're
liking it and then um you made this
video yeah about like which
music
what what was your favorite anime and
what
i think was like one of like the anime
of the year kind of thing
like
you know you had like the art category
and the animation category yeah the
music category yeah and he made this
like great joke like about the fact that
i was aussie
there was there was this one clip that
got posted in like the behind
behind-the-scenes documentary of made in
abyss right because it's like very
professionally made documentary and
there's just this one clip of kevin
going to be like he he was talking to
someone yeah and i i can't remember the
exact line but he talks about oh yeah
can uh uh this he's like you you you
refer to someone as like a mate or
something like that right yeah so yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
um dimitri was the guy i was doing right
he's uh amazing he's he's like the main
violinist and all the abyss right right
he is
like the bosses of bosses when it comes
to right right right unbelievable his
big dude boys yeah yeah yeah yeah like
he's like
trying it's good sorry i don't do a good
impression of him
because i don't play violin and play
flute yeah so i checked with college
friends before going over i'd be like is
this [ __ ] this is [ __ ] up if i give
this to someone in a recording studio
yeah so obviously remember like when you
go into a recording session that's
[ __ ] thousands of euros or dollars
whatever it is like a [ __ ] hour like
yeah
like five figures easily in a couple of
hours yeah like eight hours some
depending on how many people you're
hiring yeah yeah super expensive
scenario to be like oh the flute player
wrote [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] violin
lines
so checking with friends or mates
beforehand was exactly what i did oh and
i was trying to be chill about it i was
like yeah no no i just checked with like
a mate and like that but the first day
he did not understand he's uh he's uh
he's austrian-american yeah right he's
like with what i'm like with a
with a friend
[Laughter]
yeah i mean
i checked with a mate but he seemed to
say that was okay
with him with a friend okay and but but
for some reason it felt really cool to
have like that you know that
response from this youtuber [ __ ] guy
yeah so actually like and then i started
getting really curious about okay that
this lovely gentleman over here is
thinking like this about you know maybe
who else is thinking about like what
what does everyone else say
like [ __ ] attitude is where the
reason i got back into anime oh [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ] holy
[Music]
conventions and then i saw that you were
gonna be there i was like yeah
oh i must i must say hello yeah all
right all right i've i've been enjoying
it yeah i've been enjoying the content
and i have it ever since because like
like i remember because we were both
going to control expo and i was like oh
kevin's going and you know when you like
i don't know why right you just you just
you just like bring out this aura of
just like he's a lad
he's a [ __ ] lab
all right that was extrapolated just
from that one clip that's like oh i
checked with the mate and then yeah
check with the what and then just you
just see the paddock being like
ch check with the friends
wrestling [ __ ] face classic
and i was just like from that one clip i
was like seems like he seems like a
ladder yeah
i of course we met the first time at
like the bar or something right yeah
it's like yeah yeah yeah yeah fitting
yeah yeah where where where is the more
fitting place than meeting meeting each
other and i i was are you a gig yeah
yeah and it was like i was like prepared
to be like are you kevin oh my god i'm
like a big fan of your work made in the
best was absolutely amazing lo and
behold kevin comes up to me and taps me
on the shoulder yeah and i like like at
this time you know annie i like annie
she was like way smaller than it is now
so like i i'm just like a random guy who
got just like invited to this anime expo
i've been really excited to meet people
in the industry people have actually
worked on anime and then kevin
taps me on the shoulder and be like are
you giggup i [ __ ] love your work i'm
like why are you saying this to me
i should be saying this to you it's true
no but that's the thing i came from from
the exact same position right right just
happy to be i'm not happy to meet people
yeah i meant really i mean
because of that show i'm here yeah right
right yeah right right we we got to get
now i got like a wee and yeah it's like
what my name is my first time eating is
when you ordered too much chicken so
that was that's a bonding experience
we can yeah we can because yeah trauma
is very rare
is very good i've never been back to
that change yeah
well the first time i made you was at an
izakaya in uh in shibuya and that was
and you were just like oh you want to do
long high
and at first i was like who's this bloke
and then and then i realized it's
[ __ ] kevin i was like oh i gotta take
four magnus is
yeah so of course like crunchyroll expo
we like immediately bonded over [ __ ]
getting pissed as a
british and aussies of course but like i
remember you got to a point of drunkness
where you started like spewing some
really interesting [ __ ] about your
creative process i've made in the best
yeah i did that last night
like for some reason there's like a
certain drunkness level where kevin gets
really eloquent about talking about his
creative process and music and he was
talking about this one track which uh
which was played over like a very
spoilerific moment in made in this
season
it was a very emotional moment and he
was talking about like using like
juxtaposition and like techniques that
he learned from like
university university in college and i
was just i remember being like i was
pretty toasted i was just like this is
really [ __ ] interesting i just really
like as like an anime fan i would love
to hear this when i'm sober because i'm
like not remembering anything so like i
i put a mental note to ask him about it
the next day when i'm sober and so
received so we can explain in more
detail yeah it's really [ __ ]
interesting so i go to kevin i was like
kevin you were made talking about this
track and made an abyss and like how you
came up with that and what process you
did yeah like can you like explain to
that because that is really [ __ ]
interesting and he just looks at me and
goes i'm gonna do what the [ __ ] i said
mate
no he like kevin kevin did that to me on
friday he went he went off about this
one synthesizer for like two hours then
he's like he's like you don't understand
when you put your finger on it it's like
50 springs 50 springs on your finger and
it feels amazing it's amazing
it's like velvety and it feels so good
and i'm just like oh
yeah
imagine putting your finger on um like
you know where i'm like
divers uh like not skin type of skin
like a wetsuit what diver what yeah so
there's a i got a synth that's made out
of diver wetsuit with all these
different springs underneath and you
play it like a sea board so you can like
you play synths and stuff but it's like
a leopardos sort of thing all right you
assume i know what a c board
oh yes
imagine a piano but with no keys and
it's just a line
yeah that's a seaboard yeah
like
like that
piano
is that something that they did like the
[ __ ] jerk it out meme on
imagine that but instead of a pen it's
your finger okay
yeah so he was going off about that
right for like what felt like two hours
and it was really interesting but i was
these exact same situation i was like
i'm really happy this is really cool
you're showing me all these like youtube
videos and there's like really loud
button i'm like having to do this
yeah it's like really like specific
um but you want sound yeah
like i was like oh it's a 43 minute
video just let me scrub for a minute
it's just
yeah but it's good to hear it's like
great when you're hearing someone who's
like so passionate about it yeah yeah
yeah i mean to be fair like
i do actually [ __ ] love it like you
know
i might like joke about it a little bit
oh i don't remember how this [ __ ]
happened but you know it's like it's
like at least like you know as like a
fellow musician i understood the
majority of what you were saying i can't
imagine what it was like the gun right
it's just like hearing all these like
musicology terms i just might be like
yeah have
i asked about like the doom soundtrack
and you were telling me about how
yeah to compose it he got some russian
synth and i was like oh i was like you
were telling me i was like i was like i
was like yeah
yeah in my head i was like i was like i
understand that
it being from russia could add to the
sound of sounding more dude
yeah yeah i was just like i'm in my head
i'm like does the russia have a lot of
influence on the synth being like more
dooms
like is the soundtrack of russia just do
like all right so so yeah i feel like
i've like once i tired you out i like
went yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you were the
next victim because we were like sorry
let me tell you about russian
synthesizers yeah i was like i was like
i don't know any synthesizer but i'm
open to him um yeah so the polyvox is a
soviet era synthesizer that um it's it's
about 50 kilograms and it has like the
one one of the most gnarly [ __ ]
sounds because you got to think of okay
the synthesizer is basically i mean
among other things it's voltage being
put through an oscillator okay so it's
like it's a [ __ ] biblical sound it is
beautiful and the way that you can shape
these oscillators and then filter them
through different effects and stuff
makes a synthesizer's character come out
so like yeah different types of
processing that you have this
i mean you can just listen to the
oscillator bn oscillator but at the same
time the way that it's processed through
certain other like kind of effects and
boards in a synthesizer
gives it a certain unique character this
is exactly how we sound
depending on how it's made the pickups
and stuff like that yeah it'll have a
different characteristic yeah think of
it like that but
electricity okay right and so this
particular synthesizer that yeah was was
used in the doom soundtrack and i
i would love to get one but like they're
no they're not easy to get you know yeah
it's like they are dated instruments now
yeah that is the thing so is your house
just uh filled with men insurance and
synthesizers and a bunch of other random
stuff because i use yeah so um my
[ __ ] i guess call it both a quarter
life crisis and like my pandemic kind of
like
pandemic crisis right right
[ __ ] [ __ ] covered sort of like yeah
outlet was just to fill this room with
just all this [ __ ] [ __ ] to just yeah
yeah and like it's it helped it helped a
lot yeah
i mean i saw you tweeting about it
constantly right so i'm like yeah
but like that's the problem is that like
all it took was for me to ask about this
like one one particular synthesizer that
i really liked
all i said was so kevin i heard you
bought a moog and then and then he just
went off for two hours
so let me tell you my life story yeah
now we always think like what's the
opposite of you know the horse girl well
apparently it's the synthesizers
[Laughter]
the synth guy i'm still trying to figure
out why i tried to make you think about
what a moose sounds like
i don't know why i picked that
see this is a problem i'm too sober it's
funny
i'm not making enough [ __ ] yeah
between like dysfunctional and
functional yeah functional dysfunctional
again why would i just decide
yeah yeah i know everything is upside
down is up exactly